hello my name is yakachi douglas  annihilations  to nigerian teacher olasinkomi operifa  who is a finalist  for the global teacher prize 2020.  hola sun comey it's an incredible  achievement to have been chosen  from over 12 000 applications and  nominations from across the world  you make every nigerian proud especially  your students  you are a true inspiration always  thinking out of the box to help your  students  gain the education they deserve you even  help them improve their english with  hip-hop songs and dance steps which is  incredibly amazing the world is facing  many challenges  climate change conflicts and global  pandemic so now more than ever we must  equip  young children with great education so  they can view the better future  and that always starts with teachers  like you or lasun coming  thank you